uh finishing with the day with one  armageddon and  flying pieces but uh not yesterday it  was a quiet day at the office  and we see my muse carson here so look  you have a lot of experience what do you  think  will magnus try to get his revenge today  well you know how is magnus he is the  typical uh revenge guy yeah he he  doesn't forget  and yeah this was also basically my my  problem when i was i was dealing with  nothing let's say off the board  i was always teasing him you know like  stuff i was sure that he was going to  play his a game against me  and also taking sometimes some risks  which we're not  really justified but  yeah he had good good relationship i  mean he liked to  you have the sense of humor yes yes well  he was mocking you i remember  one time that the price officer asked  him that's